there's a good chance you've either
played flappy bird or at least you've
heard of it it's easy to play you simply
tap the screen to make the bird fly and
avoid obstacles you get points for
successfully avoiding the pipes but if
you hit them or crash into the ground
the game is over
a flappy bird was highly addictive so
much so that it ruined the life of the
guy who created it at one point dog
nguyen was making 50 000
a day on the game from ads yet he
removed it from the app store and google
play less than a year after its release
why did he walk away from what appeared
to be such a success
our story begins in hanoi vietnam in
2013. don nguyen was a 28 year old
programmer who lived with his parents he
made a living programming location
devices for taxis as a teen he was
obsessed with video games like super
mario bros and also learned to code he
played the app angry birds but thought
it was too busy there was too much going
on that inspired him to make flappy bird
over one weekend he wanted to make
something simpler that you could play
while on the go his company gears
released the game on the app store on
may 24 2013 it went live on google play
in early 2014. he decided the game would
be free he hoped to make a few hundred
bucks a month from the ads within the
game but little did he know the fortune
that lay ahead
initially flappy bird didn't attract
much attention tens of thousands of new
apps come online every month competition
was tough
however about eight months after
releasing the game
something strange happened people
started talking about it really talking
about it how they were addicted to it
how they were frustrated by it how they
couldn't stop cursing after losing
flappy bird adhered to atari co-founder
nolan bushnell's principle the belief
that all the best games are easy to
learn and difficult to master
whenever you played you felt like you
could have done better and that made you
want to try again and again the game was
all about skill
most people usually lost within the
first 10 pipes or so you got a point for
every gap he passed through if you got
10 or more points you did exceptionally
well
the physics was especially impressive
floppy bird was inspired by the act of
bouncing a ping-pong ball against a
paddle for as long as possible whenever
flappy nose dived you felt you were
along for the ride whenever flappy died
it wasn't so much that flappy died but
you died by january 2014 the game topped
the charts it was the most downloaded
app in several countries including the
us it helped that pewdiepie reviewed it
on his youtube channel there we go baby
here we go
why is it so hard
by february 2014 flappy bird had been
downloaded more than 50 million times
netting nguyen 50 000 a day in ad
revenue you'd think he'd be the happiest
man in the world
but no on february 8 2014 he tweeted
that flappy bird was ruining his simple
life and that he grew to hate his own
game
the following day he tweeted i am sorry
flappy bird users 22 hours from now i
will take flappy bird down i cannot take
this anymore
this came as a shock
why on earth would anyone remove a game
that was so insanely popular generating
50 000 a day even after apple and
google's 30 cut of the revenue
instead of being thrilled about his
success he was very very unhappy
in an interview with rolling stone a
month after taking the app offline he
said he found the sudden intention
suffocating he said his parents didn't
know about the game until the paparazzi
showed up outside his door
when journalists started reaching out to
him for interviews he pleaded with them
to give him peace
even worse than the media attention was
the criticism from some users he had
intended for the game to be played for
just a few minutes at a time as a
relaxing break but in reality that's not
how people use the app they were
addicted
he showed rolling stone a message he
received from a woman who chastised him
for distracting the children of the
world another person wrote 13 kids at my
school broke their phones because of
your game and they still play it because
it's addicting like crack nguyen
apparently took these messages to heart
quote at first i thought they were just
joking but i realized they really hurt
themselves
in an interview with forbes shortly
after taking the game down he explained
it happened to become an addictive
product i think it has become a problem
to solve that problem it's best to take
down flappy bird
on february 10 2014 flappy bird was no
more
knockoff soon flooded the app store it
was a valley effort but people still
craved the original some tried selling
their smartphones with flappy bird
already downloaded for as much as a
hundred thousand the game was still
playable there just wouldn't be any
software updates however one seller said
ebay canceled his auction because the
company policy was that the phone had to
be restored to factory settings before
it could be sold
after the demise of flappy bird fake
news stories swirled around the creator
the satirical site huzzlers claimed the
flappy bird creator had committed
suicide there were suggestions nintendo
had threatened to sue him which he
denied the popular gaming site kotaku
attacked flappy bird's creator for
allegedly ripping off nintendo's art
kotaku later ended up apologizing
the addiction the spotlight the
criticism all proved too much for nguyen
it appears money no matter how much
really can't buy happiness
nearly two years after the end of flappy
bird nguyen appeared to be in a much
better place in december 2015 he tweeted
i'm really happy these days i finally
have a team that i fit in and we work
together well not alone anymore he came
out with a bunch of other games and he
said that if users thought they were too
addicting he wouldn't hesitate to take
them down as well
but luckily for him none would come
close to the success of floppy bird
if you'd like to create your own app or
product a strong background in stem is
really important my go-to tool for
brushing up on science computer science
and math is brilliant if you'd like to
learn how to make a computer do what you
want brilliance algorithm fundamentals
course is a perfect place to start by
the end of the course you'll have an
understanding of the methods to measure
and compare performance and you'll have
mastered the fundamental problems and
algorithms brilliant is great whether
you're in high school university or if
you're already working it's full of
interactive questions like these my
personal favorite are the logic courses
in this example you have to put things
in the correct order they get harder as
you go along and build up to some truly
mind-bending challenges there are no
tests and if you ever get stuck you can
view the explanation to see where you
went wrong brilliant is free to try out
if you head to brilliant.org
newsthink my custom link is in the
description or pin comment and the first
200 people to use my link will get 20
off brilliance premium subscription
which gives you unlimited access to all
the offerings
thanks for watching for news think i'm
cindy palm